hello everybody it's Jo the locksmith in
this video we'll be doing all keys lost
to a 2018 Toyota Camry bladed key system
with the altel
km100 first we'll turn the ignition
on I'm choose
emo
Toyota manual selection
USA
Camry 12 to
20 blade
key
yes control
unit
mobilizer check number of keys
okay we'll do all keys lost mobilizer
reset
okay okay we'll open the driver's door
okay make sure the driver's door stays
open one
key
okay turn the ignition
[Music]
off turn it back on
okay turn off remove the
key
okay turn the Eng back on
[Music]
ignition Off remove the
key
okay okay inert the master key turn the
ignition on and quickly turn the
ignition on off five
times on wait 5 Seconds
turn the ignition on and off five times
fast all
right okay security light is
off should be able to start the vehicle
all right all right the key is
successfully
programmed just make sure she
starts perfect light is out car starts
and runs
that's all keys lost for 2018 Toyota
Camry with the autel c 100 thank you for
watching have a great day